pour catherine gabrel cette énumération
est flatteuse mais trompeuse si la
commune de royer dont elle est maire la
porte en tête cela restera parmi les
exceptions de cette soirée
car à 40 km d'ici dans la permanence
louhannaise de cécile untermaier les
bons résultats tombent les uns après les
autres
certains surprennent même la députée
sortante frontex était très très
compliqué oui mais moi je joue je sais
pas je suis très étonné mal des
résultats très heureuse de voir qu'on
tourne en tête dans des communes rurales
ouais auquel je suis très attaché et
puis même dans des villes ou de droite
qui finalement parce par ce vote
acceptent de travailler avec moi et de
me faire confiance à royer kathryn
gordon levitt rendu à l'évidence les tic
est en marche n'a pas suffi ça a été
vraiment une expérience enrichissante et
jeux non j'ai pas de regret je reste en
marche parce que je trouve que c'est un
mouvement qui est qui vaut la peine
qu'on compte soutiennent donc je reste
en marche
je suis persuadé que ben il faut le
temps que ça s'installe mais j'espère
que dans cinq ans en définitive avec
3000 voix devant sur sa concurrente la
victoire de cécile une terre meilleurs
et même bien plus large qu'en 2012 face
à arnaud danjean et cette victoire la
députée sortante la tribu à son action
de député c'est la seule explication
possible c'est effectivement que je les
ai convaincus pendant ces cinq ans est
bien de l'ags la qualité du travail que
nous pouvions mener ensemble et
moi je m'en réjouis je les félicite j'ai
une pensée bien sûr pour mon adversaire
parce que je sais que c'est pas facile
et je peux lui dire que c'est encore
plus difficile de perdre quand on a déjà
le mandat frédéric cannard le binôme de
la candidate vient de recevoir un texto
d'arnaud montebourg qui fait dans la
métaphore sportive de fait cécile
untermaier a bel et bien réussi
ça remonte à 2